a contest from another era Kiev was the
more effective the remain position which
costs were fifty to six in the north of
England what do you want from the next
Labour leader some of this honest as
Jeremy Corbyn was bought with the
personality and the showbiz EBA to be
able to complete with the rest of the
ideas are out there a competition
answering yesterday's question we need
to leave everyone was arguing about a
future that will bear no relation now to
the one who we fight it is a fork in the
road if people think more of the same is
going to cut it frankly it won't but
maybe after that December election
results leaving behind much the recent
past is for the best
we saw them numbers come up and it was
literally as if the ground fell away and
a little voice said Rebecca maybe they
don't want socialism
[Music]
when this contest began in December
vastly inflated welfare payments for
millions and unparalleled government
intervention was a korbinite dream not a
Tory reality and after the election
drubbing in December frankly Labour
looked as if it could do with a bit of
social distancing with itself
now the ballots for the leadership
contest were mostly cast before
coronavirus hit hard does that help or
hinder the New Labour leader the story
of the last four months has been how
jeremy corbyn's fearsome political
network momentum key unions and an
enlarged labour membership really
struggled to dominate the leadership
conversation yet to listen to some on
the left you would have think that
they'd achieved their goals the center
of gravity over all the shifted and in
some ways but labour hasn't won the
argument judging by the worst election
defeat for the party since in 1935 and
some on the Left were struggling to even
accept December's election result to be
honest with you I don't trust the result
I really don't and I can't prove it
nobody can or we would sure be trying to
but come on the postal vote Fiasco since
December many Jeremy Corbyn fans
explicitly haven't wanted change from
thanks Labour leader I wasn't kind of
continuty
but many unions including loyal
supporters have Corbin through tough
times disagreed the opposition is a
price worth paying for purity any longer
it is a fork in the road if people think
more of the same is going to cut it
frankly it won't and I would say to
those people what are you really
interested in are you interested in
power because that's all my members are
interested in they don't want another
five years let alone another ten years
of conservative law talk to Labour MPs
and peers look at polling the fork with
a contest with kiss Dharma and Lisa
Nandi on one side and korbinite
favourite Rebecca long bailey on the
other what difference would having
along Bailey as leader make compared to
the others future of the Labour Party
what is it that Rebecca long really
offers that has understood why we went
backwards and is going to change it I
haven't seen anything since December
many Jeremy Corbyn fans who in this
contest were turning out in droves to
support Rebecca long Bayley explicitly
didn't want change but the candidate
favored by jeremy corbyn's allies said
this defeat was not about substance it's
a matter of communication about our
policies and I think we didn't have a
campaign that I had a message or be
picked out certain policies that were
popular and tried to package them in a
way that would be articulated to our
communities properly well we were also
faced with a backdrop of other issues
such as practices such as anti-semitism
such as division within the party
we've got arise again and understand how
we've actually shifted politics to the
left
even her supporters admitting it's more
about who is making the promises than
what they are promising pierced armour
to carry out and continue with the
policies which would pursue for four
five years the race to replace Jeremy
Corbyn gives please about what a new
leader faces with kiss Dharma and Lisa
Mandy spending the contest pledging
unity another korbinite favourite this
time for the deputy leadership used his
platform to remind audiences who was
unfaithful to Jeremy the way you stopped
by our socialist politics the way you
stood by our anti austerity and to our
international politics in the same way
I'll never forget those who let us down
I'll never forget those who betrayed us
I'll never forget those who handed the
victory to the Tories on the plates in
2017
that to a packed Hall was the leading
next-generation korbinite with John
McDonnell smiling on approvingly is
Richard Bergen really helping the next
leader by revisiting who resigned from
the Shadow Cabinet in the 2016 coup
against Jeremy Corbyn I don't think he
should have resigned I don't think Lisa
Nunda should have done the same I don't
think she should have been shared
Owen Smith's campaign to remove Jeremy
Corbyn but ultimately they let the
members down Peter those Labour MPs let
the members down he turned what was a
crisis for the Conservative Party the
David Cameron on his way out into a
crisis for the Labour Party as far as
I'm concerned that was absolutely awful
and insult really to labour members
across the country but also to labour
voters who rely upon his remaining
united John MacDonald to does the blame
game will be a characteristically more
in sorrow than anger
well skier Aunt Lisa we're part of the
coup against Jeremy Corbyn so I take I
do take that into account but voting
members in this contest haven't been
able to see that much difference between
the contenders the policies are pretty
similar between them and that's what
really matters
the question of this leadership contest
was going to be whether or not kiss
Dharma and Lisa Nandi needed to endorse
quite so much of jeremy corbyn's
manifestos given that they lost two
elections in the grip that momentum and
korbinite allies appeared to have on the
party it seemed like a reasonable
assumption but has coronavirus white
clean more of jeremy corbyn's legacy for
good or for ill if the left decide not
to fight the present they can point to
the past
and claim victory how much do you think
that this leadership election is a
referendum on Jeremy Corbyn I think if
it's a referendum on Jeremy Corbyn he's
already won because if you look at the
policy consensus in this contest all the
candidates are saying they're in favor
of public ownership of rail and kind of
core utilities all of them are say
they're in favor of scrapping tuition
fees all of them are kind of anti
austerity now those positions
weren't party positions when Jeremy took
over as
later British politics in the landscape
of the nation has changed beyond
recognition once more the New Labour
leader inheriting a party further to the
left at any point than since Michael
foot is now having to navigate how
closely to work with Boris Johnson and
working out what an opposition does in a
national emergency it is a course to the
unknown Sam code Sky News